our 21-day voyage is finally beginning
this is our big anniversary trip so we
decided to come back to France that's
our first stop and then from here we're
gonna fly over to Morocco and spend some
time in Morocco and explore Africa
[Music]
I'm like super excited we went to Japan
and we're going out over the Japanese on
the wall how are these like an Arabic I
guess the upside about doing a tour is
that we didn't really need to do any
sort of studying prior to being here cuz
I figured we'd learn it on the tour so
you know we're lazy American very very
lazy but I'm excited to learn to eat and
everything else
[Music]
this little tiny I was like the biggest
thing ever this is so cool your Casa
Blanca look at all the white buildings
house of white we're gonna have a lot of
bug problems here don't hit the
chandelier keep coming after me I kind
of love her pink so old it has so much
character
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to Morocco welcome to the la
Blanca
you have the White House in Washington
we have the White House so because I'd
like that mean White House in Spanish
[Music]
what's that mean
they go Echo Lake almost said
say thank you shukran shukran shukran
[Music]
Moroccan air day 1 this is the day 1 of
our tour gonna be exciting so we left
Casablanca we're heading to robot I
think or 10 June or he said like 3
different city names but ultimately
we're gonna end up in Fez and we're here
we are in a pee break yeah you look like
you're very Moroccan right now I know
everyone I'm very much it's very
appropriate Walmart guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now wherever in macness or outside of
macness the little pit stop so you could
take some photos moroccan ants careful
there's a lot of dangerous things out
here so make nests it's a walled city
it's because it's one of the past
Imperial cities of Morocco and another
thing that I'm ik ness is known for well
there's a lot of flies everywhere
another thing that big nest is known for
is its the wine city so Moroccan wine
originates here and that we just passed
by the big Moroccan wine factory oh yeah
well you know listen to people you
listen to the tour guide
[Music]
I'll sleep in the bus so now we're
outside mullah III village so mullah
every
man that brought Islam to Morocco and
this is the place where they welcomed
him and Islam with open arms
that's a sick ride
[Music]
you better get another town right now
I'm a rocking tonight we are now walking
doing a tour through booth at least it's
very ancient most of the underground
excavating it pretty cool that's the
gist
I forgot the numbers do this is part of
the original Roman Road I mean Morning
Glory the other one Morning Glory some
reason all the information I'm getting
it's like and when you're not the other
and I forget immediately rather luminous
flower-mobile is in the lobbies
you found me you're royalty no please I
make you my king huh that's right
now I'm gonna have you plugged in my
hipster nose it'd be easier and become
afraid you know well the camera can't
get it but there's so many nestled in my
queen would you like to enter your
palace it's your palace you're the queen
[Music]
right so a little village and we're
about to have a whole meal so cool it's
part of the tour it's like to support
women and stuff awesome it's called
planet era pretty dope I'm so excited
[Music]
we're at the second hotel now everyone
a user is minty minty Oh yummy you
blending right into the wall
[Music]
I guess it makes your happen straight
kind of ominous a total upgrade total up
from last night oh you downgraded the
chandelier though oh yeah alright
anyways we are finally in Fez
so we drove it's benefice yeah
princess oh yeah we driven how long did
you drive today we left at 8 a.m. it's
5:30 p.m.
yeah with a couple pit stops and you
never forget every single name that I
hear yeah if you're watching this for it
as a travel video
it's a terrible travel video like it
we're not paying attention very well
alright it is golden hour and we are
exploring this
[Music]
we didn't realize this we find a rival
we realized that we've come to Morocco
during Ramadan and according to Ramadan
they are fasting the entire day and they
have like this prayer called five times
a day every time you pray and like
cleanser stop is they're really
beautiful
like so sundown to about 3 a.m. here at
least that's the time that they can eat
and then the rest of the day after that
there's no eating no drinking nothing so
in other words in a few in an hour or so
when the Sun Goes Down it's about the
Apopka non these streets so we are
assuming dinner and breakfast and
breasts for Thea which is a it's like a
meat pie actually kanpai yeah call so we
ordered grain don't super excited about
the couscous tal and Spanish bombs like
rumpled chickens Oh mm-hmm
I'm not sure but the cinnamon and the
sugar gives it a really interesting like
sweet on the outside savory on the
inside melting your mouth from the
inside the crunchy on the outside that's
me baby does need to of Morocco frenetic
sports
[Music]